上個月我們剪過諾貝爾經濟學獎得主 Daron Acemoglu 的訪談
他說決定 AI 往哪走的
是一小群讀同樣科幻小說的人
這一場是 9 月 20 號上架的
他拿美國跟中國來比
主持人指出
他談自由民主的新書完全沒寫中國
其實中國可以拿來當成自由民主以外的另一種模式來談
不過我還是決定，不要讓論證變得更長、更複雜
但沒錯，我認為只有中國這個模式
威權體制還沒有完全爛掉
我推測，中國有些部分運作得還不錯
但我認為，這有一部分也是自由民主國家自己的弱點
技術上沒能跟上中國，製造業的底子也沒能跟上中國
主持人接著引了一個說法
西方過去 150 年的好日子
靠的是技術跟經濟上領先全世界
現在這個領先沒了
不，技術領先非常重要，而我們確實正在失去它，這完全是事實
但某種程度上，我認為自由民主的政府
更有機會把技術領先拿回來
話說回來，我們為什麼會失去技術領先？
第一，中國有些政策做得很好
撐起了它的製造業跟經濟
這是他們的功勞，但有很大一部分是我們自找的
西方各國政府一口氣撤掉了貿易保護
讓很便宜、有時候還有補貼的中國製造品
湧進市場，摧毀了自己的產業
在 AI 跟科技上，我們把所有資源都押在 AGI
還有那些非常複雜、非常龐大的基礎模型上
結果你老是聽到一句話，「美國的 AI 領先中國」
我們在大型語言模型上，大概領先 6 到 16 個月
但你去看科技的…其他每一個面向，中國都做得很好
他們領先美國、英國、大部分的歐洲，應該說整個歐洲
把機器人跟 AI 整合進生產流程這件事
把 AI 用進電商跟直接面對顧客的產業，他們也領先
而且他們在兩件非常關鍵的事情上，投入了大量資源
一個是製造業的底子。他們有龐大的製造業，帶來很多邊做邊學的機會
也有很多機會把 AI 跟技術用來提高生產力
另一個是他們有一大批技術非常好的工程師
要把 AI 整合進生產流程的每一個環節，這一點太重要了
這些本來都是我們也做得到的事
美國沒有投資在工程人才上
其實我認為，移民帶來的技術對美國非常關鍵
是美國能繁榮的一大助力
但依賴移民工程師，等於讓美國的政策制定者有了藉口
不必投資自己的教育體系
Acemoglu 分析過蘇聯
蘇聯的經濟一度表現不錯，後來垮掉
他認為是因為體制做不到創造性破壞
主持人拿中國反問他
那為什麼中國看起來，比現在的資本主義經濟體更會做創造性破壞？
如果你把創造性破壞看成一個分散的過程
新點子從底下冒出來，挑戰既有的想法、做法跟策略
那中國其實沒那麼厲害，這個過程還是被管得很多
中國真正做得非常好的，是把已經有的
技術路線跟業務發展得極度到位
比如你看他們的 AI 產業
他們做出 DeepSeek、Kimi 這些模型
是工程上的奇蹟
怎麼把現有的方法用得又省錢，他們做到了極致
好，也許他們用了一些蒸餾技術
去反推更先進模型的部分權重（蒸餾是拿別的模型的回答當教材來訓練自己的模型，拿不到對方的權重）
但他們真的做得又便宜又漂亮
你再看他們的製造業，同樣是工程上的奇蹟
每一個環節都在想辦法最佳化
所以站在最前面的，是比亞迪、鴻海
鴻海是台灣公司但在中國有大量業務
還有華為
因為它們都是大公司
新血進來挑戰整個體系這件事，還是不怎麼活躍
這會不會變成
中國經濟往後發展的障礙，還要再看
中國的人均 GDP 還沒到西歐、英國或美國的水準
但正在快速接近
訪談最後，主持人問他
英國的生產力從 2008 年到現在幾乎沒有成長
該怎麼辦
他先講了幾個原因，撙節、脫歐
中國的競爭
而我認為 AI 其實可以帶來一些機會
這不是說英國該跟著美國走，正好相反
我認為英國可以專攻開發有用的應用
用更有遠見的方式，把 AI 整合進我們的生活
跟生產流程，做得比美國公司更好
更以勞工為中心的…
以勞工為中心、親勞工的 AI。對，親勞工的 AI，這可以是英國的未來
所以這就是你開的政策處方。假設 Andy Burnham 的政策幕僚正在聽
你會跟他們說什麼？
親勞工的 AI，要怎麼做？
我認為還是要從應用開始，伸手就摘得到的果子太多了
護理師、電工，我們能幫他們做的事太多了
老師、科學家，我們能幫他們做的事太多了
不去取代他們，不去模仿人的才能
而是給他們更好的工具，擴大他們的專業，讓他們做到以前做不到的事
做更有創意、更創新的事
英國需要更多創新，全世界都需要
因為氣候變遷、人口老化，還有全球勢力的消長
而在可預見的未來，創新還是一件
需要人才的事
所以問題是，我們怎麼給這些人才更好的工具
對，這一點在書裡也看得很清楚
你談了非常多自動化，但重點不是取代人
是增強人的能力，把生產力的提升拉到最大
沒錯
這一點我們真的已經忘了，對吧？
百分之百。這就是 AGI 這條路線造成的
AGI 這條路線不知道怎麼辦到的，讓所有人都相信
AI 最好、唯一、而且必然的用法
就是把它做得越來越像人，直到它比人更強
最後一個問題，為什麼這麼多人買單？
這是華府史上最厲害的一次遊說
還是背後有更深的原因？
我想一部分是歷史
科技業本來就在往那個方向走
微軟、Google、Oracle 都是
靠賣自動化工具給企業才變成巨頭
另一部分是科幻小說
真的，我認為 AI 這個領域從一開始就深受科幻小說影響
科幻小說的固定戲碼，就是機器變得跟人一模一樣
然後接管一切、威脅人類
這是我們想像出來的，從 1950 年代就一直在講
而我們越是想要它，就越是把它變成現實
照 Acemoglu 的說法
美國押在 AGI
只換到大模型上一點領先
工廠裡的 AI 已經輸給中國
他要英國別跟著美國
讓 AI 去幫護理師、電工跟老師
原影片 77 分鐘
大部分在談他的新書
他也講到
AI 公司老闆一談人類滅絕
薪水跟不平等的討論就被蓋過去
原影片連結在說明欄，有興趣可以去聽更多。